[Music]
[Applause]
keep trying don't give up your head up
hold
on got to be
strong keep trying don't give up hold
your head up hold
on you got to be strong
I woke up this morning I saw the
sunshine I thank the Lord for giving me
a brand new
[Music]
day I grab my keys and I'm out for work
another trouble day head in my way I'm
not
worri he's a friend of
mine he with me all the time I believe
in him I believe in him I trust in
he's a friend of M
[Music]
he's
him keep trying don't give up head up
hold on keep your head got be it got to
be
strong trying don't give
[Music]
up
hi I'm Tor Ean from time management
chef.com Evan corich newsletter epic
subscribe